OUR NIC PARKER COVERING THE
STORY FROM MEXICO CITY.
NICK, THIS IS A GUY WHO USED TO
PUT HIS ENEMIES IN DRUMS, POUR
GASOLINE ON THEM AND SET THEM ON
FIRE.
TELL US MORE ABOUT HIM AND HOW
HE WAS CAPTURED.
>> Reporter: YEAH, THAT'S RIGHT,
MICHAEL.
I MEAN, HE REALLY HAS BEEN A
PIONEER OF SOME OF THE MOST
GRUESOME VIOLENCE THAT WE'VE
SEEN IN MEXICO.
YOU KNOW, OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS.
AND AS YOU SAY, THE LEADER OVER
ONE OF IF NOT THE MOST POWERFUL
CARTEL IN MEXICO WITH TENTACLES
STRETCHESING FROM CENTRAL
AMERICA THROUGH MEXICO AND ALL
THE WAY INTO THE UNITED STATES,
HE WAS APPREHENDED ON MONDAY
MORNING AROUND 3:45 IN THE
MORNING IN AN AREA JUST SOUTH OF
NUEVO LAREDO.
THE KEY CITY FOR THE TRAFFICKING
OF DRUGS.
MARINES SAY THEY HAD THE AREA
UNDER SURVEILLANCE FOR SOME
MONTHS PRIOR TO HIS
APPREHENSION.
AND THEY CAUGHT SIGHT OF A
PICKUP TRUCK ROUND ABOUT 3:30 ON
MONDAY MORNING.
AND THEY LAUNCHED A JOINT
OPERATION INVOLVING A HELICOPTER
AND GROUND TROOPS.
THEY WERE ABLE TO STOP THE
PICKUP TRUCK WITHOUT A SHOT
FIRED.
AND THEY FOUND TREVINO MORALES,
$2 MILLION, EIGHT WEAPONS AND
TWO OTHER MEN.
AN AREA WHERE HE BASICALLY BUILT
HIS CAREER IN THE DRUG INDUSTRY.
HE STARTED AT A LOW LEVEL, A
STREET LEVEL IN NUEVO LAREDO.
HE APPARENTLY LIVED IN THE
UNITED STATES CITY OF DALLAS,
HE'S THOUGHT TO HAVE LIVED IN.
BY 2005 HE WAS RUNNING
NUEVO LAREDO AND BASICALLY
TRAFFICKING MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
OF DRUGS INTO THE UNITED STATES.
AND APPARENTLY ACCORDING TO U.S.
PROSECUTORS HE WAS ALSO
ORGANIZING HIT SQUADS TO CARRY
OUT ATTACKS WITHIN THE UNITED
STATES.
SO HE WAS